okay von bushido und anna-maria fertig
um die beiden geht es ja jetzt ist
eigentlich eher sie die starke sie hat
da schon ganz schön die fäden in die
hand und die beiden cds tatsächlich weg
aus deutschland familie flasche geben
möchte ausländern
ich bin zu hause ist einfach zu hause um
wäre heute alle sachen aus rumpeln da
wird demnächst um die familie verstieß
sie packt die koffer mutter vater sieben
kinder ziehen bushidos familie will weg
aus berlin weg aus deutschland und sich
ein neues ungestörtes leben aufbauen und
ich hätte mich dazu zwingen auch nun die
sachen zu behalten und wirklich mich
schon einmal zu trennen weil ich so ein
umzug ist immer richtig gut dafür da
richtig auszumisten alsfeld - es ist ein
neuanfang nach jahren der angst einem
leben unter polizeischutz und ständige
öffentliche aufmerksamkeit rückblick
nach jahren der freund und partnerschaft
trennt sich gangster rapper bushido 2017
von arafat abou chaker jahre lang war
der kleinbus nicht nur sein manager
sondern auch einer seiner engsten
vertrauten
bushido rappt wird zu einem der
erfolgreichsten künstler deutschlands
hvd und seine familie bauen ihr clan
imperium auf gemeinsam hätten sie
millionen doch dann der bruch bushido
will raus aus dem milieu sein leben
ändern für die familie
exklusiv bei bild äußert sich der rapper
im oktober zu den gründen alfert und dem
ab und jacqueline den rücken zu kehren
an dem tag an dem morgens auch dass das
lka und teilweise auch andere beamte
dann bei uns im kinderzimmer stand und
unsere kinder in ihrem kinderbett
standen da aber auch für mich ein punkt
wo ich gesagt nein ich will dass ich mal
doch der kleinbus lässt seinen
schützling nicht einfach ziehen
erfordert millionen von bushido doch der
will nicht zahlen aus freunden werden
feinde der höhepunkt 2009 10 aus
racheplan arafat und seine brüder einen
säureanschlag auf bushidos kinder und
die entführung seiner frau anna maria
seitdem steht die ganze familie unter
polizeischutz keinen schritt ohne
bewachung kein freies leben mehr eine
schwere belastung auch für die kinder
unsere älteste tochter hat war sehr
verunsichert eine ganze zeit auf grund
weil sie die personen die die die
bedrohung darstellen persönlich kennen
das hat sie glaube ich tief erschüttert
und ich weiß nicht was das für
auswirkungen haben wird später aber sie
hat das bewusst wahrgenommen und
barbara touren ist nur noch neben mir
gefahren auch wenn die polizei und zwar
alle personenschützer die ich vom lka
kennengelernt habe durchgehend sind
absolut super nette korrekte typen und
genau also mit denen ich noch viel
lieber zeit verbringe als mit
irgendwelchen typen die ich aus der
vergangenheit kennen und das muss man
sich mal vorstellen ein leben in sorge
um die ehefrau um die kinder um die
familie der rapper macht sich bis heute
schwere vorwürfe ich habe diese leute
ich habe dieses diese dieses diese
atmosphäre diese flair und diese
entourage und diese kultur die habe ich
den das leben meiner kinder gebracht
abschließen können die fesche hieß auch
nach jahren nicht seit sommer 2020 läuft
am berliner landgericht der prozess
gegen arafat und drei seiner brüder
bushido ist zeuge und nebenkläger die
früheren partner und freunde sprechen
nur noch vor dem richter würdigen sich
keines blickes bis zur bushidos und anna
marias hochzeitstag vor wenigen wochen
als arafat diese gruselige video
nachricht an das glückliche ehepaar
richtet sich als euer trauzeuge wünsche
euch zum zehnjährigen nun das aller bist
und ich als ein ehemaliger rosa bruder
um die laternen will nur das beste für
euch und warum kümmern was als nette
geste verpackt ist ist reine
boshaftigkeit die auch als versteckte
drohung gedeutet werden kann der
geplante säureangriff und die geplante
entführung wegen erst drei jahre zurück
ein leben in ruhe und frieden scheint
für die fesche schießt in deutschland
völlig unmöglich keinen schritt können
sie unbeobachtet gehen die bedrohung
sitzt ständig in ihrem nacken ihren
wunsch deutschland zu verlassen um ein
freies leben zu führen nun wollen
bushido und anna-maria ihn wahr werden
lassen der beginn für ein neues
friedliches und glückliches leben
schauen wir mal wieder auf den monitor
neben
china und da sehen wir sie losfliegen wo
fliegen sie denn hin
weil da waren sie schon öfter im urlaub
in den letzten jahren sie lieben die
wärme sie leben das meer sie haben dort
aber auch freunde also freunde aus
deutschland die auch nach dubai
ausgewandert sind
2021 wollten sie dort eigentlich schon
mehrere monate verbringen und sich dort
ein haus mieten dann hat aber anna maria
erfahren dass sie schwanger ist mit
drilling dann wurde die geburt bzw
schwangerschaft ja sehr kompliziert und
dann haben sie sich entschieden erst mal
noch in deutschland zu bleiben dubai
luxuriös aber auch langweilig muss man
sagen das leben dort zwischen all diesen
das metall aber sie wollen sich
natürlich von diesem von dieser
dauerbewachung des lka es frei machen
sie können sich nicht alleine bewegen in
dubai fühlen sie sich aber einigermaßen
sicher für uns steuerzahler ist es auch
besser das ganze so ein polizeischutz
größeren für 600.000 euro pro jahr
und es soll tatsächlich schon bald
losgehen also eigentlich wollten sie im
juni umziehen
der ist ja noch läuft ja noch drei
wochen spätestens aber im august müssten
sie dann eigentlich laut unseren
informationen da sein denn dort beginnt
dann die schule in dubai und die kinder
müssen halt dort auch zur schule